début de soirée dans le quartier du
sanitas un véhicule de la police vient
de se faire caillasser pas
d'interpellation mais la tension est
vive entre jeunes du quartier et
policiers l ont rien à faire ici
ce qu'ils ont rien à faire ici c'est pas
chez eux c'est chez nous et ça le
quartier quadrillé par la police des
patrouilles tourner toutes les deux
minutes
un dispositif de sécurité important est
déployé à 19h40 la tension monte d'un
cran
le fait est mis à une cage d'escalier
l'immeuble est évacué
je suivais le jour là le subitement ans
l'entente du lait la fumée et l'odeur
tout ça là et ma femme est sortie pour
voir où il y avait la fumée partout bon
après on en sort tu vois question en
pyjama on est sorti on comprenait pas de
quoi il s'agissait et j'avais cru - le
feu une propulsion donc la première
greffe elle ne se nourrit pas j'ai aussi
connu et ma famille je suis descendu
c'est une réaction en chaîne qui
s'ensuit
à 20 heures un premier véhicule est
incendié rue mioches
les pompiers ont à peine le temps
d'éteindre le feu qu'un second véhicule
est pris par les flammes dans une rue
adjacente
vingt minutes après deux autres voitures
sont incendiées place albert philippon
c'est en quelque sorte le jeu du chat et
de la souris entre les jeunes et les
forces de l'ordre
la population est excédée vraiment tendu
depuis tatillon on n'arrive pas devant
demi ils sont fatigués des hélicos qui
sont en haut on sait pas ce qu'il se
passe entre les jeunes et les flics nous
on ne sait rien on est innocent on ne
sait pas ce qui se passe du moment
l'autre on peut venir tuer on sait pas
nous sommes fatigués de ce quartier nous
sont fatigués ci a dit bien fatigué en
nomade ses quartiers sur tout l'ensemble
on ne peut même pas descendre 21h15
l'hélicoptère de la gendarmerie dépêchée
au dessus du sanitas avec un puissant
projecteur immeubles et russes ont
scruté dans les moindres recoins
nombreux sont les habitants a assisté à
la scène de leurs balcons et de leurs
fenêtres
23h le quartier du sanitas retrouve
enfin le calme l'hélicoptère arrête ces
rondes
bilan de la soirée quatre véhicules et
le hall d'un immeuble incendié trois
personnes ont été interpellées dont deux
mineurs de 14 et 15 ans la nuit calme
jusqu'à ce qu'un autre véhicule prenne
feu
ce matin à 6 heures